I'm not going to touch it, I'm just going to apply the cream
[Music] I'm going to apply it, it's very, I mean, I can't do it if you say it out loud, I'm sorry, it's
a little
cold and dead, it's
erotic to death, a
girl's back is surprisingly hard, but that's why I can feel her bones
and
warmth, and it's
already
complete.  I'm standing there, Licca-chan, and I hope you're happy.
Monkey, don't come any closer. Let's get this over with
quickly. Go back
to the pool and wait.
Now it's time for your
feet. You can paint your feet by yourself, right? No, I'm
not saying no.
Luka-chan's feet are like this. If I
touch them, I'm already touching them. How
far and how far should I apply it?
Luka-chan's definitely not going to get angry, even if it's on her thighs and groin feet.  I'm
coming
[applause]
I'm
awake.